the number of civilian owned guns around
the world is estimated at 650 million
and 270 million of those handguns rifles
shotguns machine guns and even
improvised craft guns belong to the
people of the United States there are 90
ones per hundred Americans giving the
country the honor of the highest gun
ownership rate in the world do you know
which country comes in second as far as
guns per person Yemen with a population
of 23 million there are 55 firearms per
hundred yum Emmys but that's still
almost half as many guns of Americans
even though Yemen is a war-torn country
with extreme poverty and political
instability and while Yemen packs the
second highest amount of heat per person
India has a second largest number of
privately owned guns with an estimated
forty six million weapons followed by
China Germany and Pakistan
what about gun violence the United
States is the fifth in the world for
numbers of homicides by guns behind
Venezuela Mexico Colombia and Brazil on
the other end of the spectrum Japan has
one of the strictest gun laws in the
world and also one of the lowest murder
rates in 2008 there were only eleven
gun-related homicides Switzerland
however ranks high in gun ownership and
low in violent crime about 0.5 homicides
per hundred thousand people that's less
than 1% when compared to the rest of the
world the u.s. stands alone for high gun
ownership and high gun violence despite
being a well-off country what's the
missing link is it a lack of gun laws or
is it something else
[Music]